afternoon everyone i wonder how many of
you
knew off the top of your or know off the
top of your head how many topics there
are
within extension two does anyone know
how many topics there are
complex should we count them should we
count them
complex numbers all right
let's let's let's try to do like sort of
in some order right
complex numbers last year nature of
proof
then we had a look at 3d vectors most
recently
we did further integration and then
finally there is
mechanics five topics
see how that says introduction to
mechanics do you know what this means
we're starting the last topic
this means uh as has been quoted today
we're in the end game now so
i should point out i should point out in
terms of
further integration there's like a few
teeny tiny bits
that we have not uh quite unquote
finished but if you have a look through
the silver star points that i gave to
you right at the beginning of that topic
you'll see we've gotten we had a pretty
good go at exploring those ideas
some of the textbooks exercises we've
skipped over
questions and a single exercise we're
going to return to those as we go
through
it's going to be pretty obvious actually
we are we're not going to go very far
from integration at all
in this topic but this does have a new
name for a good reason
mechanics is the final topic we're going
to do and i know that this struck fear
into my heart the first time i taught it
because as
some of you are i'm currently i was not
a physics student
years 11 and 12. and i knew that that
kind of in some ways put me behind
the eight ball in terms of understanding
and teaching this but also put me
weirdly ahead and i want to try and
explain
why there are some differences and some
commonalities between
mathematics and physics as you study
them and that's kind of what
we need to state right out of the gate
some of this will be familiar from
extension one but other
others other bits of it will be new so
these two
uh overlapping circles in our venn
diagram here represent anyone want to
guess
classical pieces mathematics
and physics thank you manuel
now as is so often the case emanuel
you're way too smart for me now
we're going to look at mathematics and
physics here and the first thing i need
to say is that i'm going to draw this
distinction
but it's a false thing to say these
things are two separate things i
remember having a
fun conversation with mr anne once when
he said to me like ah physics that you
do in high school
doesn't really prepare you for actually
doing physics
in university because you open up any
physics textbook in university
and it's just 100 mathematics you're
like whoa this
these are two separate subjects in two
separate klas right
so this is a false distinction to really
draw but there are still some important
things that we should actually highlight
are different for example in mathematics
as you studied it there's a bunch of
things that we're interested in we've
explored
even within say extension 2 that from a
physics point of view
not interested at all right after
complex numbers what was that second
topic that we did started this year
nature of proof now i would put that in
this area over here
of things that we've looked at in
mathematics
that from a physics point of view it's
like do i care what a contrapositive is
not really right it's completely off to
the side
this is not the only topic if we go back
or even think within say
the nature of proof and i'm just pulling
things out of
the top of my head right now if you go
back to say seven
and eight we're gonna look at prime
numbers like how do you decompose
a number into its prime factors right
that was a cool mathematical thing to do
nothing to do with the physical world
right and i could go on and on and on um
someone give me an extension one topic
that we've done that doesn't really have
any connection to the physical
world yeah financial
i guess i mean sure i asked for a
suggestion
so that's what i got okay we could i've
run out of space in my circle but we
could go on
permutations and combinations to some
extent you could talk about
statistics and the normal distribution
now this gets my point though right i
said to some extent
say something like statistics right it's
like well
chemistry is highly statistical our
understanding of how
chemical reactions work and of course
that's actually all driven by physics
you see why i say this is a false
dichotomy but still we can say there are
some things we're interested in maths
that physics is not and the reverse is
also
true just so we don't play this game for
a long time i thought of three things
off the top of my head that uh
we don't really worry about from a
mathematics point of view but in physics
is kind of a really big deal right
so in terms of energy in terms of
uh like all the different like i don't
know strong nuclear force weak nuclear
force
um electromagnetism like forces i guess
you would say
from that point of view those
fundamental forces
um we can talk about matter we can talk
about space these are things
that even though we can understand them
mathematically within
mathematics as a subject here we don't
really
touch any of these right but the
excuse me the area that is right there
in that sweet spot which we're going to
focus on you've already like sort of
dipped your toes in a little bit we're
going to dive right in
is what we would call motion right now
motion is a big
umbrella term and we're going to dig a
little further into what that means
in this table underneath so i want us to
think about
from a physics and a mathematics point
of view some of the key
things that separate these and they're
going to be really important especially
for those who
who do both subjects because you can't
apply one way of thinking
in the other in some very obvious ways
okay so the first one is
what's the method of how you know things
in
all sciences not just physics chemistry
biology how do you know something is
true
or reliable and not just opinion in
science
yeah go ahead by doing actually
observing yeah
we call them experiments right we do
experiments we experiment
we have experimentation and that is like
we literally call it the scientific
method
right it has to be repeatable we have to
say yes okay on the basis of this i
don't know why i chose that color i want
to
keep in in keeping with what i did up
above
i'm going to do this over and over again
i want to control for every variable i
possibly can
experimentation is the way that i know
something is true in physics right
i think about something like say the uh
the large hadron collider you guys know
about that right
a billion proton collisions
per second a billion per second it's
just insane
they have to do it over and over and
over and over again because
experimentation is the way that you know
things in physics experimentation
doesn't cut it
in maths you could give me a billion
triangles per second
and measure the angle sum of every
single one and tell me they were all 180
degrees
and i would say i don't care how many
billions of triangles you've got
that's still not proof to me
mathematically what do we use instead
this goes back to our nature of proof
topic
probably i would say it with the letter
l
what do we use we use logic right we
convince ourselves
through a process of deduction okay now
just before i come to your observation
xiao i should point out again this false
dichotomy idea it's not like physicists
never use logic
right and uh the science fact would be
very upset if i said that
and it is it's not as though
mathematicians never experiment right
but
the experiments are never enough in
maths and
in physics it's not enough to come up
with a theory you have to test it you've
got to go out and measure you've got to
put a satellite up there or something
like that
okay xiao are you going to make an solve
observation example of
the angle sum of a triangle isn't that
the definite measure of utility and
geometry
uh yeah partly that is not exactly being
through it's just we define the sergeant
yes so this is one of the things which
actually i
thought about whether i should include
it in this table or not but it's sort of
in common between these two that there
are assumptions that we just make
i didn't include engineering here
because i knew i'd be out of my depth
because mrs lee would be doing that much
better than i would
okay now i'm going to give you a fancy
name for this right well in terms of the
method of knowing
something to be true what philosophers
would call this is the
epistemological basis
this is just so that when you get to uni
you can use fancy words
epistemology is how do you know
something is true
or not right how do you know something
is true or not
the epistemological basis in physics is
experimentation
you got no experiments you got nothing
in mathematics
it's logic okay